the daily growth rate of the population
of a colony of insects okay let's let P
I know we'd like to launch into
equations and it would be freak out
probably but if you're gonna talk about
variables you need to know what they if
that's the population of the colony
Vincent the growth rate is 10% of the
excess of the population over one point
Wow okay that's good amount isn't it so
let's just start first I'll give 10% 10%
I can do this here this is a growth rate
right it's going to be ten percent zero
point one off something okay what's the
something morning the excess of the
population over that okay so there's the
population right and based on this it's
saying it's higher than that it's higher
than 1.2 times 10 decease what's that
1.2 million I guess okay so the
population is always bigger than that
and it's growing in relation to that so
therefore you've got P right and you've
got this one point two times two this is
one point two million figure right we
want to know what the excess is of the
population over that well that's that's
just the difference between these two
numbers right which one do we say was
bigger P is bigger because it's an
excess over right so therefore you're
gonna have P minus this not the other
way round okay is that all right so this
is P minus 1.2 million that's the excess
right and so the growth rate is 10% of
the excess there we go
okay you can see a lot of us just down
to interpretation language at T equals 0
the population is a negative number
2.7 million we could easily have it just
as easily said peanut butter it doesn't
matter okay determine population after
three and a half days what's the
population and sketch the curve of the
population against time all right
now you have a look at all of this and
you think about how I'm gonna put this
all together clearly and this point here
I need some kind of equation for P that
I can stick 3.5 into and then I'll get a
value okay now because you've got deep
immunity so you might think oh I suppose
integration might be a natural way to
think about how to go from D PLDT to P
that's not a bad thing to think
however being that we know it says it
some 10% of the excess information this
is proportional right this kind of thing
here this relationship we know we have a
very very good idea of what kind of
function P is likely to be even if we
don't know the exact numbers okay so
think about this you only have a few
equations to model this kind of
exponential growth right and it is
growth so that already knocked out
morning that already knocked out your
decrepit decay equations so for example
this guy he's out right this guy also
out right so it's going to be neither of
those if it's going to be increasing
it's either something like this or
something like this or alternatively
that we'd when we saw before which is
something like a2 plus something like
that okay now the reason why I lean
towards one of these is because you have
a look at this form here right if you
are women have a look when we did this
right we differentiate it to try and
look at what the graph would behave like
right you didn't get back this super
proportionality thing here you got quite
a different equation
so that's why even though this will give
you a kind of exponential birth it's not
going to be the one that I'm interested
in because the differential equation
doesn't match that okay so therefore
it's going to be one of these now B that
we know what differential equation
matches to this right it's just a simple
you know the PMT
it's just proportional directly right
that's what leads you towards this okay
hmm
so just stop there this is tricky I
wrote this all out so you could see
what's going on in my brain all right
the question doesn't hold your hand at
all it just says figure it out right and
the part of the reason why is because
when you're in exponential direct growth
indicated land okay um you know it has
to be one of these there's nothing else
that's going to match this kind of
differential equation so they're
expecting you to be able to recognize
that tuna students not so much then say
they'd probably actually give you an
equation and then say alright sure that
this matches you know this satisfy is
you differential equation which you find
that very first set of HSC questions as
often you're first in their part a show
that this satisfies this and then off
you go but it says you were students you
should know these and you should be able
to work out you should be able to deduce
which one of these is going to fit this
situation best so if I have this
situation here okay consider
okay one of the pieces of this thing
remember how this thing works
you've got the normal exponential kind
of shape right but it's been moved up C
units so something like this there
abouts okay now think about what you
know about this thing right there's
always this number here 1.2 million that
you're always above right and you're
changing in relation to that okay
therefore in terms of this piece of
information and this graph where is it
most likely to be what is it most likely
to correspond to where's the 1.2 million
it's probably the asymptote is it
because the idea the question is
assuming that you're always going to be
above just there okay so that's what
your proportional to that that distance
in there that makes sense okay so
therefore I can think about this time if
I for instance just suppose it's equal
to a to the KT plus this okay I can
actually already sort of work out from
this is it going to fit my differential
equation have I made a good guess
because here I can say well what's the P
ODT well yep your chain rule bit so the
cake comes out the front okay hey II to
the ket what happens to this constant
just disappears okay so now if I want to
turn this back into a differential
equation of this kind right
I've got K times now what is this it's
not P it's P - this isn't it it's not
the whole thing on this line so I've got
P minus 1.2 million that's a good sign
isn't it it matches now what's his K
what does that correspond to it
corresponds to the 10% doesn't it okay
your constant of proportionality
so therefore you
say well if this really should be 10%
there's one then that should be up here
that's where K should be right so you
can see if I'm trying to cut the
information in terms of what question I
think would match that okay so what I
have now is P equals e to the zero point
one there's like a plus one point two
million okay so now I've got only got
the time variable and this a which is
going to come from my initial condition
which they have given to us here okay so
let's pop that in when T equals zero
you're going to get two point seven
million on this side you can see what's
going to happen here this is just going
to become one because in to the north
right so times one plus that 1.2 million
constant is just floating around so
that's why you get your value of a and
it looks a bit one and a half million
there we go cool so now even though they
didn't ask us for it the question kind
of assumes that I need my equation for P
so I can state it now as I'm gonna have
10 to the 6 on both turns I'm just good
at the front 10 million outside of
here's my a it's the K and there is the
constant okay there you go now after
this you just substitute in that's all
you have to do I've got T there I can
put in three point five one point five
point three five but of course that
part's really trivial isn't it can we go
back and think about how did we how do
we get to this point this is the hard
way if you can get there you're done
actually right
you need to be super familiar with your
exponential growth and decay equations
alright you can immediately knock out
half of them once you know whether its
growth or decay and that part's not too
difficult to work that then you want to
think about are there constraints
involved and you judge that based on the
kind of differential equation you've got
okay suppose you have the advantage of
this exercise being all about
constraints right
so if actually lean you're even more in
this direction but when it's a general
question in the exam or if it's all
mixed up you look at the differential
equation and that'll tell you okay
that'll tell you whether you've got
regular extra doctor growth or expense
regret with some kind of constraint and
then from there it's just a matter of
reading in all of the information in
order to eliminate all of the clusters
of your hey you see your K right and
they will provide you enough information
to do that we were supposed to graph
this will we have to graph it will
probably help us to actually work out
what the value is because this will be
our point for scale it's all got the
number there I think it's like three
point something
yeah I'll just go to point three since
I've got two significant figures there
so I'm just going to do two with me so
there you go now I've got some points
that I can put onto my graph
I've got an asymptote at where was it
1.2 times 10 to the 6 so I'll stick that
for you 1.2 times 10 to the 6 I know my
intercept excuse me is 2.7 million so
that should be or should be a bit more
than double chin that's so call that 2.7
and I know that after 3.5 units of time
I'm up to here which is not all that
much higher than here is it so something
like maybe there so if you put a point
that's time three and a half days all
right it's beautiful they go okay